who knows what the MCU is gonna look
like after infinity war but they're
gonna need some new blood the shadow
knows no I'm not only gonna bother
they're trying to do a second take on
that I'm just gonna let that be ruined
by them hey everybody welcome to the
Council of geeks my name is Ann thing
away and I am joined by Ryan Daly who is
gentle in my look I'm back and I can
wear a hat - yeah 2018 we're all about
the brand council geeks so um we're kind
of doing the opposite of what it was
last time you saw us together last time
we had a collection of ideas concepts
that have appeared in the Marvel comic
books that we said should not ever be
used in the movies this time we've got
some characters some broad strokes some
stories that we think should be used and
the timing of this works out rather well
because you told me about this yeah
perfect as of the time that we were
recording this just a few hours ago
Marvel made a slew of new announcements
including very exciting they have pushed
up the release date the us release date
for Avengers infinity war so it will now
be released a week earlier April 27th in
the United States that's the same day
that's being released in the UK and the
overseas markets basically they want a
global launch perhaps to avoid spoilers
I'm just maybe just they might want more
time more lead time before solo a Star
Wars story comes out and starts even
though solo was gonna stomp all over
let me either the important thing to to
know about that now is that's April 27th
today as we record this March 1st
Avengers infinity war comes out next
month oh yeah that was only the first of
several announcements as I was
mentioning to you because what we're
gonna be talking about from this topic
is sort of the future of Marvel and some
suggestions that we have well let's look
at the future that they have officially
laid out for us yeah now this year 2018
April 27th Avengers infinity war July
6th ant-man
and the
wasp next year Captain Marvel March 8th
2019 the as-yet untitled Avengers 4 I
think it's gonna be called Avengers
forever but I could be wrong as of now
they have not released the title I don't
as long as long as the four is part of
forever I and I do believe that they
will release the official title but week
that infinity war comes out I wouldn't
be come but anyway that for now at least
is still scheduled to come out May 3rd
2019 the untitled spider-man 2 I'm
assuming - spider-man junior prom July
5th 2019 so we're now in the bargain
where Marvel is releasing three movies a
year and that trend is not going to stop
because in 2020 they have a release date
for May 1st I am 95% sure this is
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 James Gunn
has said that guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 is coming out 2020 I'm almost
positive he said it's the first one that
may release date
they also have an unnamed project coming
out July 31st 2020 another unknown
unnamed project coming up November 3rd
2020 and what they have just released is
they have six more unnamed properties
movies coming out on the following dates
May 7th 2021 July 30th 2021 November 5th
2021 and then February 18 2022 May 6th
2012
2022 I'm assuming all six of those
movies are going to be black panther
sequels or spin-offs but yeah and one
other little note the last one that they
released July 29 2022 that is going to
be the 32nd movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe holy crap ok so now
obviously we're not gonna make guesses
as what are the specific things that
actually could be doing because I'm sure
some of those will be sequels some of
those own new properties once that one's
out they're definitely going to do black
pants or - oh yeah at this point I think
we can bet some of those unknown dates
are gonna be black faith or two
three possibly almost unless the sequel
Kings why don't you I'm saying black
panther three happens I don't know
whether or not they I don't I don't know
if three turns aren't quick enough to
fit in the timeline right Yeah right
so black panther to probably black
panther three maybe not and that's a
probably dr. strange to although I
hadn't heard it he talked about it
recently it made enough money to group
to warrant a sequel but they just
haven't talked about it and it might
just have to do with how I don't think
they've had a problem working with
Benedict Cumberbatch but I think his
schedule he's just been more difficult
to manage in terms of getting him on
these properties I do it before we start
getting to our specific ideas I do have
to wonder if with with the success of
thor ragnarok
if they're gonna be looking at some of
these characters who had you know decent
but not amazing debuts like say doctor
stranger maybe looking at them to
planting them and having to about two
boolean be supporting characters rather
than try and force them continue a
franchise that ends up being on the
lower end of the armor
and I would be fine with them using
Doctor Strange for that purpose that
actually feeds into something that I was
going to bring up later so so let's get
into this are we talking about the x-men
and Fantastic Four in terms of I'm not
I'm not either
because I first of all the team with Fox
isn't that set in stone yet it's not I
mean it's it's very it's unlikely to
fall apart but there's a ton of
logistics to go through and even after
that you'd actually transition
everything over it's not gonna be like
'hot deal done x-men movie comes out
next year like if possible maybe some of
the 2021 stuff it could be but but like
you said the deals not final they're not
walking in dates for x-men no no I do
believe they are working on stories
though if they have four years they does
somewhere just as a pipe dream yeah some
lowly separate your formula come up with
a story for what this movie might be so
here's the first one that I marvel would
be stupid to not be planning this right
now because we're getting Captain Marvel
we dang well better be getting Kamala
Khan MS Marvel I I just think that's an
absolute no-brainer the only thing that
becomes a question mark is and this
largely depends on how they layout
captain Marvel's
backstory in her own movie as to whether
or not she ever held the identity of MS
Marvel but that's not even a requirement
because you can still have Kamala Khan
idolized her as Captain Marvel ago well
I can't take her name I'll be MS marble
you know it doesn't even have to be that
she's adopting Carol Danvers former name
yeah but Kamala Khan in case folks don't
know she's she's an inhuman she has
powers that are basically kind of a it's
a variation I'm stretching yeah it's I
think the term that she uses most
frequently is in beginning yes she has
the Mbeki fist to basically get this big
edex people but she she is a young
Muslim teenager
Muslim American and and she you know has
in some ways it picks up on some of the
spider-man stuff as well she has my
balance you know family and feel and
doing and doing all this but it is a
different approach she is approaching
this because she wants she has a joy in
what she's doing you know Peter Parker
has he can't have that but he's he's
largely driven by guilt great power
great responsibility he feels
responsible Kamala Khan just kind of
wants to do good in a bit more in the
abstract but I Chi is hugely popular
she's one of the best new characters
they've introduced I'd say in the last
decade
oh I I think if they aren't moving on
this right now then somebody needs to
lose their job I'm like this character
all lot I think the Marvel Cinematic
Universe would be better for her for
some reason I can't get this out of my
head that I just think her destiny is in
television or a streaming format and not
the big screen I hope I'm wrong because
I would like to see that movie but just
the the relatively small-scale
street-level nature of her story so far
that I've read which is the first two
years I think of her comics that I've
read so far like it surely doesn't fit
into the world of the defenders and
flicks heroes like daredevil okay it
just off such a different tone idea but
feels like more of that level to me well
see you say that but spider-man
homecoming didn't go much beyond that is
true that is true now do you want it to
be too much like that or do you well I
mean like that to me is the one sort of
potential issue is finding a way to
distinct because they have made
spider-man so she long right um it's not
a problem in the comic she doesn't feel
like she's stepping on Peter Parker's
toes because in the comic but not on the
movie they would be agent Probert
contemporaries and they have kind of the
same tone yeah so that would be that
would be the one potential issue is not
having it feel like we're doing we're
doing the same thing we're doing with
spider-man but with this character so
they would have to find some other ways
to distinguish that I think it's doable
it's that that's just a pitfall to be
aware of okay what you got well this is
sort of not necessary good character
specific we'll get into something
characters out actually no you know what
let me go back oh god I will start off
focusing on a character that I would
like to see a Spider Woman Oh number of
spider women to hold a minor I'm
thinking about the original one Jessica
drew the one the one issued before I
even lit well let me lay out sort of
their story first so her very
complicated backstory is to simplify the
most event she was experimented on by
her father who was a scientist and she
was bitten or poisoned by a dangerous
spider almost died the Hydra was
involved in sort of genetically
manipulating her to give her powers she
ends up becoming an agent of Hydra then
flips kind of becomes more of a hero the
one thing that I kind of see is her
story is she can sort of play it as some
of the the black widow things now if
they make a black widow movie we'll see
but I like her as a character who has
this Bachelor of being a Hydra agent who
was flipped and now could be hunted by
both sides okay and that comes like the
story I see is more of like an espionage
Bourne Identity type of thing where
she's being hunted by shield and Hydra
think she knows meanwhile she's
discovering the new powers that she's
been given with because of the way she
was experimented you can get an
international favor because I believe
her father was British and she spent
most of her time in the UK so I always
hear a British accent in my head when I
read her okay so I think we have casting
something like that with Emily Blunt or
something else to me younger green
before you've agreed was my default for
any sort of villainous woman but yeah
she'd be great a Spider Woman to some of
the more recent comics they've actually
given her a daughter or like they
actually made her pregnant and
continuing to fight contracted crime as
a wild woman well visibly pregnant yeah
I don't know what I would lead with that
but it would be different that see
here's the thing part of me says you do
that as your follow up but another part
of me thinks maybe you should lead with
that and here's why I like what you've
sold but if they're making a black widow
movie then the espionage yeah you know
that's going between two sides niche is
likely already filled and then we run
into the same problem that Kamala Khan
potentially as with spider-man whereas
if you come at this it could still be
espionage II but if you lead with the
wrinkle oh and she's pregnant that's a
pretty that's a that's an immediate way
to distinguish that's one of the
problems with Marvel's women as much as
I love their female characters a lot of
them are spies or secret agents or ninja
say all kind of have like the same stick
yeah yeah you're right yeah even the
super-powered ones kind of fall into
that when mystique got our own bones
they they made that in espionage kind of
some electrons things like that yeah huh
it's a solid pick though I like it
so I'm gonna I'm gonna do one now now
normally when I talk Marvel I talk
almost exclusively the movies and the
reason for that is I don't keep up with
all the other stuff anymore at this
point there's Netflix stuff that I
couldn't finish I've fallen off ages of
shield I've been told it got it got good
again after season three which is where
I quit I think they're prepping for
season 5 to be the last one that what
I've heard is they they're having to see
Analia the series finale for season 5 to
be a place where they can leave it but
they could pick it up again if they get
renewed so maybe attending but if it
does I would want this in its place
okay and that is she-hulk
here's the thing so she hope backstory
super simple she is Bruce banners cousin
she got a blood transfusion from him
because he was a compatible donor they
did not realize that the his condition
of being the hope basically transferred
over in a form over to Jennifer Walters
so the specifics have varied for a while
she was set off by rage that got dropped
after a while and primarily at this
point for most of her run she's been
able well she's either been stuck in
green and can't change or she could
switch back and forth at will and she
retains her full intelligence and
everything when she is she now the
reason I want this on TV I really want
to see the single green female I want I
want Sommers know I love the dance lot I
want I want Ally McBeal she's six foot
eight in green because Jennifer Walters
is a practicing lawyer and there was a
and that's been the case for a long time
but it wasn't until Dan Slott that they
really ran with this and they had her
working for a law firm that specializes
in superhero related legal matters so
it's things like helping a guy who got
superpowers in an accident but do you
want them try to sue the company that he
the head he worked for spider-man suing
the Daily Bugle for libel or defamation
of character
yes JJ yeah that was one and so it's
stuff like that and I think I think that
absolutely I think that is a much more
unique thing than anything else you
could probably do with her um in terms
of the things that she's known for and
has done over time and it it does lend
itself to television because you have
your episodic why we following that
story in that type of direction yes I
yes you you haven't you have a new case
every episode and I just I that I just
think that's a really easy fit and
and also in terms of the tone of what I
would put this one on ABC and in terms
of the tone of what those shows tend to
be I think that being a good tone will
fit as well I really I love she-hulk not
as much as you but pretty close and I
love that run that you were talking
about I really like this idea I knew you
were gonna focus in on this character so
instead of coming up with a different
idea I just came up with a couple of
questions yes
does the origin story work into today
knowing what we know like Bruce Banner
could would he ever allow would shield
with any agency ever allow a blood
transfusion from him to go to any other
person let alone a relative you would
have to finagle it here here is my
thinking and it would it would take it
would involve contrivance to be frank
about it but if because I don't think I
don't think the fact that Bruce Banner
is the Hulk is public knowledge as yet
in the end the MCU I believe that is
still under wraps now I mean the
military obviously no--nor who the hell
he is I don't believe the public at
large has been informed that Bruce
Banner is the Hulk I could be wrong that
but I don't belong ourselves okay so
what I would say is if we're in a
situation for where Jennifer Walters has
her accent she needs a blood transfusion
and if we're in a situation where just
to talk something again this is off not
my head so this is contrived but say for
the time being because he isn't sure he
can control himself Bruce banners in a
medically induced coma in in the
hospital where she gets checked it now
the records that these that these people
at the hospital have having if it
wouldn't have anything to do it just be
like monitor him keep an eye on him
here's the number that you call if he
wakes up but they're like oh he's
compatible and there you go and it
becomes an emergency snap judgment that
gets made to try and save her life that
has unforeseen consequences is there a
better way to do it yeah probably but in
terms of the doing it completely
straight with him voluntarily giving is
what no no
it doesn't work I wonder if looking back
at the Incredible Hulk movie that so
often gets forgotten maybe something to
do with Samuel Sterns who last saw
looking like he was becoming the leader
or something like that
we never yeah that play out if he still
had samples of Bruce's blood and DNA or
something and then how he his symbol or
whatever whether he tried to create
another one with her or it was an
accident something like that now I try
and cut Bruce out of the process
voluntarily altogether that's not a bad
idea I don't know if they're willing to
dip back until you brought you to me
Ross back they did bring general Ross
back but they also let I think that I'm
losing the actors name all of a sudden
but they let him jump ship because he
was in fan for stick oh yeah so they not
they obviously Tim Blake Nelson thank
you they obviously didn't bother
retaining him I mean they could sign him
again fresh but it's very clear that MC
that the MCU has not had any plans to
they use him in the wake of that film
right well so then one other question is
what would she look like as she-hulk
would it be a practical or CGI yeah my
ideal would be practical well on a TV
budget would have to sure so what you do
is they never get if you're not familiar
with character you can look at the comic
cover she does not look like this
enormous range monster she usually looks
like a 7-foot tall beautiful green
Amazon yeah so so if you can catch
somebody like that
well you can't cast it exactly but I say
you you get somebody I mean I'm not
necessarily saying cast her because I
I'm not sure she'd be a fifth the part
but if you get somebody of the physical
stature of whether Chris thinking about
her to ant but and then you just use
force perspective to make up another six
seven inches on top of that give you're
golden yeah I don't think there's any
need to go CGI with him because even
though she's large her proportions are
muscular but not and not impossible for
a human being to maintain
the question cuz I knew you were gonna
bring her yeah yeah you know me too well
myself alright
what else he yeah okay so thinking about
again 2020 we believe guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 I understand this could
always change I believe that it's going
to be the end of the contract for some
of those characters and and actors has
definitely said it's the last one he's
doing and he's planning on bringing that
story to a close right so I think we'll
see probably the end of you know
star-lord Rocket Gamora Drax by the way
I'm not expecting all of these
characters to survive the two Avengers
movies we've got coming up it wouldn't
surprise me if at least one character
from the guardians of the galaxy world
is dead before we see garden from galaxy
93 well they're they're gonna have to
deal with the more a nebula if nothing
else right right
I also think Drax might be on the
chopping block but I don't know anyway
so after that now jinto has said that
that's the last one that he's running
and directing for this but Kevin Feige
sort of gave him the keys to the cosmic
realm and just said help us figure out
where we go with this corner of the MCU
after the audience is over so are you
saying what what does he set up in
Guardians 3 for them to keep it going
perhaps yeah and just where where else
can they go he's all but confirmed that
Adam warlock will be introduced in
guardians of the galaxy line three
resumed ibly as a threat at first yeah
and then probably having his Redemption
coming back and you know a good guy
if that works if the character is good
if they like the actor the performance
everything he may be somebody who can
carry the load of yeah that's the easy
go tune and probably adapt some of the
stories that jim Starlin did with him
where he's fighting this group called
the universal Church of Truth which is
led by a character named the Magus and
then it is revealed that the Magus is in
fact a future advanced version of Adam
warlock himself yeah so but more purple
more purple and great with way to [ __ ]
yeah yeah that was actually the
storyline that introduced Gamora too so
that's just one
the directions that they could take with
the cosmic realm as you know an Adam
warlock story game is only leave-taking
on the mages and the universal Church of
truth figuring out this threat from his
own future and the paradoxical natures
of that in those comics he had a
sidekick named pip the troll I forgot
about basically yeah that's basically
the Lannister Tyrion series yeah Syrian
conflict in the figure yeah basically
Tyrion Lannister just with chopping on a
cigar so a story like that could be cool
other cosmic characters that they could
introduce quasar I don't know enough
about that character solo adventures we
would have to ask our Pat casting friend
gene Hendricks yeah cuz he's more the
expert Nova you've got a variety of
options if you go know about yeah and
once you integrate the Fox properties
you can look at stuff like Silver Surfer
and other things sort of in the
fantastic program I I would actually
Yami you can also you can have a lot of
the x-men properties occupy that as well
sure yeah the Shiar starjammers
basically could take place the guardians
of the galaxy yeah a space pirates there
they could totally feel that nice you
can it you can you can use mojo yeah oh
yeah but sort of the the other big sort
of cosmic level threat that I think they
could do and I think they want to and I
think James gonna has said he wants to
do it but I don't know if they have the
right to it would be the annihilation
wave from the annihilation comics which
is basically Annihilus
from okay opens up a breach and
basically just floods the galaxy with
these like bug insectoid aliens that
just overrun and decimate whole
populations the scrolls the Nova Corps
everybody just like wave waste and it
was like a huge event in the comics that
just spent all these different like
miniseries that led to one big thing
really cool story and I think it would
be a good cosmic level threat that could
bring together and warlock any of these
other characters any survivors from
guardians if they do have a few
remaining things like that that would be
a cool sort of events but I don't know
if they need to build it up but it would
be another good
global threat movie yeah that we work so
this is actually character that I I have
to admit to not knowing very much about
okay but what little I know I want to
see him hmm
that's moon night okay so imagine Batman
but crazy and imagine Oh hold on not not
like the obsessive way that were you
seeing Batman be no like multiple
personality schizophrenia crazy and
that's that's basically moon night and I
mean you have to be a little nuts to be
a street-level visually operates at
night and wears all white mm-hmm she's
daring them to take a shot at them yeah
and like I said I don't actually know
much about this guy but I know that's
the pitch that's the logline I'm like
yes please
he has been interpreted so many
different ways in the comics from a very
grim and gritty Batman type to a more
grim and Frank Miller back to a very
sort of cynical brutal dream and it's
it's very I mean it's a we are you
thinking about for a movie or I mean I
think putting my any form of television
you run the risk of being another
daredevil yes because that kind of
treatment
I'm sure there are people would say put
him on that but the thing is I know
Netflix has kind of carved out its niche
as the street-level stuff and that's
fine but I don't think that you got
diminishing returns from Netflix so the
shine is kind of off that as well I
don't want to go down that rabbit hole
right now just because somebody is
ground level does not mean they have to
be on Netflix that's not a requirement
so I think a lot of people's brains
default to that I think he would be
perfectly suited um to a film and I
don't think there's any need and again
especially because if you are talking
you know just ground level in the you
know in the shadows in the alleyways
vigilant easy
yeah it's daredevil you've got that in
the TV format Marvel does not currently
have that in a film format the thing
with this character that I think I think
the thing that sets him apart that makes
them the most interesting is the
schizophrenia and the multiple
personality disorder I also think that's
the thing especially in today's climate
that they need to tread very very tight
I would agree and actually and just to
cover our own buzz I need to check which
it is because multiple for size and
schizophrenia are not the same thing I
recognize that I need to check which
condition he actually theoretically has
but go on
I think it's multiple personality to say
yeah he doesn't hear voices
well it's nesting in some comments he
does hear the voice of his Egyptian god
comes you talking to him Wow okay so
perhaps he could have both so we've got
we've got yeah it's moley it would be
Mulberry he has three different
identities at least three different
identities oh yeah okay so traditionally
depicted with the ID just disassociative
identity disorder yeah
so yes they would have to tread lightly
on that but also honestly if they it's
not necessarily a matter of treading
lightly in terms of like we need to be
really careful and barely touch on this
being almost it just has to be a matter
of treating it respectfully because
honestly we're living in an age where
mental health is a conversation that is
happening more so I mean if nothing else
how often do we hear as part of ongoing
conversations about any number of things
how often do we hear you know we need to
improve mental health it's not an awful
starting place to be that he the system
has failed him in terms of helping him
manage this and in terms of looking at
these movies as ways of representing
more a more diverse population now with
when they start Wonder Woman Captain
Marvel and Black Panther movie
headlining a character with a mental
disorder might be something yeah that
could be powerful and could it could be
profound for a specific kind of audience
as long as it's not done in an
exploitative manner which is
you slip into but you know if whoever is
working on it knows going in you know
it's not it's not just a gimmick let's
write let's treat this seriously
yeah it could really work you've got the
violence and the beating up criminals
for the exploitation we've still got
that we're covering our bases so yeah he
would be that would be an interesting
one to do to be especially if they kind
of tackled it that way I'd be interested
sticking with another single character
again I don't really have an idea for
this one he was actually I don't this is
this is one that I wanted to approach
because I really like this character and
I just don't know what the place for him
is now and it's namor the sub-mariner
okay
DC's version of Aquaman looks a lot like
Namor into certain to a certain degree
and they're gonna beat Marvel to the
punch and you're Aquaman will be out and
based on the the prep the sneak
screenings the test screenings that
they've done Aquaman is looks good
comparable to Wonder Woman in terms of
being an enjoyable excitements well it's
not like that movie could come out bomb
horribly and Marvel would say see this
is how you do it with Namor so I think
if Aquaman is a success story do they
have do they have a need or a reason to
do a Submariner and I don't know if they
do but I just
I'd like the character as a solo
franchise if if Aquaman succeeds
Neymar's a solo franchise at least
leading with that is dead in the water
I think instead what you do is you go to
his roots within the primary Marvel
Universe and you make him a villain
first and I would be fine with that as a
foil for the Fantastic Four the only
other thing is if they did a a flashback
Captain America movie with the invaders
and had him in World War 2 but I don't
even know if that's worth it uh yeah I
would I would be fine with him as a foil
for the Fantastic Four yeah I mean the
Fantastic Four or I mean it you could
even have him be a foil for other folks
but I mean that could be the way that
they answered you know
Aquaman because if if Aquaman is you
know the man who is bridging the peace
between Atlantis and the surface world
Namor is the guy who's a friend who
looks at the surface world and goes you
know how much better everything would be
if that was just gone so you know this
but it doesn't work if you launch it as
a solo franchise because then he's an
also yeah so if you introduce him as a
villain and then depending on how that
takes maybe he gets his own from after
that but I think that's where you start
right yeah I think that's probably best
way to go so I've got a couple more we
got two left this one is one that I
continue to be surprised that we haven't
heard them working on in some capacity
and this one could be TV this could be
film mm-hmm blade they got the rights
back to blade mm-hmm a couple years ago
not a peep zip zero and zilch I don't
know if his contracts tied up with the
previous franchise means that they still
have to deal with Wesley Snipes in some
capacity I don't mean like having to
star him I don't know if they have to
buy him out of some party I mean
contracts or somebody that and I could
imagine them just not wanting to deal
with him TV show I I would think stuff
would have expired by now if that was
the case right now you know Marvel we
have basically a representation of the
primary Marvel Universe once the Fox
actually acquisition goes through we
will have a representation of the x-men
side of the universe because honestly
that is kind of separate from everything
else we've got representing for the
cosmic side of the universe you know we
don't have the horror side of the
universe the horror the supernatural
closes we've got his Doctor Strange who
really only dips his toe into it the
blade is a known property he is known to
be successful he is that he is the lead
in and to this entire side of Marvel's
back catalog so I was actually going to
talk about this too and this was going
to be one of my other things and you
mentioned the difference or corners of
you know you've got the x-men verse
you've got the mainstream superhero New
Yorker Avengers yes you have the cosmic
universe you've even got a smaller
pocket defenders universe in this Quran
what about the Marvel horror universe I
would love for them to explore this more
than just blade but believe would be a
central part of this and I think to give
it its own little brand it's a little
stamp and to really isolate as a corner
that where it doesn't feel like you're
you can connect to the Avengers but
you're not necessarily intruding on them
I would take characters like blade like
Morbius Ghost Rider your favorite I
think so okay Disney's upcoming
streaming service yes I would put them
on that and because the format could
shake it doesn't have to be like a 13
episode like season show these could be
direct to streaming movies or they could
just be shorter seasons that are like
three or four episodes or something like
that like the Netflix Castlevania thing
which was just like four episodes of
some but they were still really short
you could it was a movie they've broken
before right but you could do like
limited things like that with some of
these characters but just but but that
also do like half the half a budget of
like one of these Avengers movies where
ever you don't need to be that big but
you kind of create this own little world
in itself in this horrible but you can
find them on the streaming service you
can do a blade one maybe with more
business or maybe Morbius gets his own
one a main thing one a scarecrow one and
all these things and through those you
can build up to a you know midnight sons
spirits of vengeance type of crossover
event movie things like that but you
take a little bit of time with it
two things know the first is I would say
since they bought this since they've
apparently got the modern version of
ghost writer over on agents of shield I
would say maybe not necessarily
introduced ghost writer but interview
I forgot that he was even introduced
Johnny Blaze okay who maybe is currently
beaten the curse but he's still tied
into all okay so I say you use him in
regards the idea of putting it on
streaming there's one big problem with
that and
in terms of how I would like to see
these characters depicted okay
Disney is said there's not gonna be any
r-rated content on that streaming
service which caps it at a pg-13
which means pg-13 vampires pg-13
werewolves pg-13 blood vengeance and I'm
not saying it's impossible to do that
and do it well I know it can be done
well but if Marvel is gonna explore this
corner of things I want this to be where
aside from the Netflix if they wanted to
put them on Netflix fine that wouldn't
work too but if they wanted to go movies
rather than TV series I would like them
to go harsher and we know that that is
not completely out of the realm of
possibility especially with these
characters I mean Blade all three of the
blade movies were already all r-rated
that's the expectation of this character
so with all of that in place because
they they said cuz they were
specifically asked about Deadpool mm-hmm
when the Fox acquisition started going
through now Deadpool specifically
because of how long this takes it's
possible that Deadpool will have wrapped
up his usefulness by the time to
actually get their hands on but they
have said if we get him we're not gonna
make Gibbon pg-13 will allow him to
still be R which of these plants the
seed that they may be open to new Marvel
properties that are I don't ever expect
we'll see any of the ones they've
already established being upgraded up
nor should they no no absolutely not but
I could see that I could see again blade
being a good hooking cuz he's the known
quantity being the way that they can go
there and start to deliver that kind of
stuff but it can't be on that streaming
service okay oh I didn't know I didn't
know about the rating restriction on the
streaming service and I see if there was
another I really just went to that
because I just thought of giving it
another another sort of medium another
delivery device would kind of set it
apart and give it its own little no and
also just the it would it would make it
easier to just sort of fight the idea
that these movies have to have a two
hundred million dollar budget I don't
like I mean for the horror ones I mean
you can make them scare you can make
them cheap one house knows how to make
she will be holy God yeah you know yeah
oh how awesome would it be if he worked
on blade yeah oh man guys I can't
remember who said it I just remember
when the first blade movie came out I
just remember hearing one of the reviews
was you know Wesley Snipes fights
vampires even more effeminate than Tom
Cruise and Brad Pitt I loved those first
two blade movies I really do I like the
first one I don't remember the second
one very well I think something about it
I didn't like and I didn't see the third
one but I really ones not very good yeah
well you know that was David gory
writing and directing David guerre only
works if his script is put in the hands
of a much better storyteller than him
okay so that's play and you got anything
else I feel like I kind of took that one
from you but yeah okay so okay - really
quicker and what is sort of a bigger
conceptual thing so I think looking at
what nice guardians of the galaxy sort
of fits or fills out for the universe
but it's not part of the cosmic realm
you've got an ensemble group you've got
a built-in team that didn't have to be
put together from other from other you
know established character so you've got
your core group of characters and it's
light-hearted and it's fun and it has
its own little realm there's another I
think we can tackle another group
similar to that and it might have been
tied up up to this point with Fox I bet
it actually was but assuming the rights
get revert back to Marvel and Disney
alpha flight well this is a property I
actually I don't know that much more
about other than their appearance I know
they're they're the Canadian super
government super team and I know that
their guest appearances in the x-men
books I've never actually read I don't
think a single issue of the Alpha Flight
Solo comic it is beloved by some of our
friends on but looking at that group
that idea of just a Canadian super team
and you got interesting cures but now
this could also be a place because we
said that once we get the x-men we don't
want Wolverine right away no we don't
want him sucking up all the oxygen with
the x-men the first go around give him
some time
Wolverine could be introduced in an
alpha flight not necessarily as a major
team member but as a Canada because he
was part of that group before the x-men
he was he could be one of their missions
could be retrieving him like they're
going out into the Canadian wilderness
to find this missing diamond pumping but
when to go they ever could be that or
even if you don't have him appear since
it's all set in Canada used right yeah
but you can seed the Weapon X project
you can see Department K now concede all
the things that were involved in the
creation of Wolverine as we know I am
even if you don't introduce him flat out
in that film right so with the Alpha Phi
characters you you know you got your the
main character James Hudson had several
code names I can't think of the names
right now in this way Heather you've got
puck this little short of stature guy a
sasquatch shaman a Snowbird now you also
have North Star and Aurora and with
North Star you get potentially the first
LGBTQ character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well right now at least in
the films I don't know where they stand
on the TV shows but in the films I don't
think they have an acknowledged
lgt LGBTQ character or hero North Star
would could potentially be their first
so that's something else well there's
that and they correct me if I'm wrong
and you may not know either don't they
have decent First Nation membership yeah
yeah they do know any in terms of like
just yeah in terms of having more
representation across the board too in
terms of like the the Canadians
welcoming and First Nations and just
like the the spiritual aspects of that
too with shaman and Snowbird you could
do yeah I think there's just a lot and
that'd be a fun little group that end
every word every sentence with a sorry
sorry that was a cheap shot somebody had
to do it okay no I like that so I've got
one more okay I've been saving this
welcome been building up to this one
is the big one no I think this is this
is a completely untapped angle and I'm
one of the way I'm gonna what I'm gonna
propose to do with this character and
I'm gonna write exam I wonder I bet I
can guess oh really
we'll see I think that Marvel needs to
figure out what they're going to be
doing with Bob agent of Hydra I thought
you were doing Squirrel Girl
no one that squirrel girls theoretically
in the new warriors thing if that gets
work um it's enough Bob agent of Hydra
and I'll even go specific on this so
this is looking a little bit down the
ways this is assuming the Fox
acquisition goes mmm um be because
Disney is not getting the Fox Network
because they can't because they already
own ABC they can't own more than one
right um publicly accessible you know
through signal network however they are
getting effects okay and there is an
animated show that started on FX that is
going to be wrapping up in the next
couple of years and that's Archer
mmm-hmm and that will leave a very
lovely niche to be filled I say bye Bob
agent of Hydra and if you've never heard
of this character the name kind of says
it all he is this hapless minion whose
best keeps bumping into and up against
and is in all these situations but is
never important never does anything
right somehow maybe they just did not
get killed
oh I could just see like that like that
teaser whatever he's just like he just
happens to stumble into the elevator in
the Triskelion during Captain America
Winter Soldier part of the group that's
there to capture Captain America he's
just there I got this phone Rossum I
wasn't just elbow to the nose and that
in a nutshell is Bob oh yeah I'll be
good again the only other things that I
I kind of wanted to mention was
hope that Avengers four is not the end
of the Avengers franchise and I can't
imagine I can't imagine him so I just I
hope it continues with characters like
Captain Marvel Black Panther ant-man in
or the wasp if they survive the vision
and and Scarlet Witch Falcon you know
even in these get to survive and I did
mention it last time
I hope the I hope Captain America
continues as a legacy of some sort
whether it's Chris Evans continuing
character I about that maybe Bucky picks
up the shield I just want that to
continue I'm looking at the type of
threats they could face I think a lot of
people are looking at came to conquer me
to time-travel of future stories which
you a jet I also think that might be an
issue in Avengers 4 so I don't know if
they won't do that but it was something
that I was thinking I don't remember if
you mentioned this oh yeah yeah so not
having Doctor Strange or spider-man an
official member of the Avengers but so
that they could actually kind of team up
and I do think is important that
spider-man not be an official Avengers
member because the character was better
off when he's not and also because
Marvel Studios does not own the rights
to that character so I don't want them
to handcuff them their plans to
spider-man and have Sony changed the
deal or if Sony decides to sell off
their entertainment vision the way Fox
says maybe Marvel doesn't get the
winning bid maybe a video skype them and
says you know what we don't like that
deal we're keeping spider-man for
ourselves yeah so but anyway back to
Doctor Strange not having him the other
ventures member but maybe he gets
scooped up and do another Avengers thing
and maybe the threat is something like
Mephisto and you have an Avengers super
1 or day yeah but you could have an
Avenger supernatural for it word stead
of fighting robots or aliens they're
fighting demons or something like that
they'd go to hell
something like that could be interesting
and different ya know that war gonna say
if we don't get a doctor strange to a
mom who could be the next big bad I yeah
if you're if you're going to if if they
decide not to give Doctor Strange an on
going solo franchise Dormammu is
certainly a threat that warrants the
event so that's it those are the idea
that we have the characters the concepts
that we think Marvel should so Kevin mr.
Yee I know you watch so you know give me
a call
well we'll figure out some more details
but also Tygra Black Knight Hercules
Wonder Man Captain Britain white tiger
tiger
thank you so that those are our ideas
what do you folks think what do you
think about the ones we suggested what
are some characters that so far have not
been announced or appeared in any Marvel
related entertainment outside the
comments that you think should be
integrated where do you think they would
fit whatever your thoughts are drop
something down on the comments let's
talk about it this guy's got a whole
bunch of bots whole bunch of podcasts
I'm gonna have another drink hmm a whole
bunch of podcasts that he does I'll link
to one of them down in the description
I've got all this all the stuff to do
like support me on patreon or buy a
t-shirt or follow me on Twitter listen
my podcast etc etc links for everything
including his junk will be down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
seriously eight untitled Marvel
Cinematic Universe properties coming out
in the next 12 years five of them are
gonna be Sheree movies I would go see
everyone
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]